[Music]
tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates he
was the first target of the special
counsels investigation pleading guilty
to lying to the FBI about his contacts
with suspected Russian operatives
tonight George papadopolis and his new
wife Simona tell their story love and
loathing in the age of Trump as he tries
to build a case for a presidential
partner Plus Alex Jones the conspiracy
theorist caught in his own lies and
fabrications under oath and I myself
almost psychosis back in the past right
basically thought everything was staged
you've not now learned a lot of times
takes heart states but are his wrath
protected by the First Amendment and our
shoutout for the reporters in Dallas who
investigated what the police dashboard
camera could not see leading to the
exoneration of these two men it feels
really good from the law and crime
Network studios in New York City this is
Brian Ross investigates
good evening and welcome tonight the man
who was target number one for the
special councils Russia investigation
George papadopolis convicted of lying to
the FBI about his alleged contacts with
Russian operatives
it was his claim that he had been told
the Russians had Hillary Clinton's
emails that really started the whole
Russia investigation his new book deep
state target how I got caught in the
crosshairs of the plot to bring down
president Trump George and his wife
Simone oh now join us live from Los
Angeles with their version of events and
their story of love and loathing in the
age of Trump
mr. and mrs. fotopolous up of us thank
you for being here thank you for having
us thank you for having gas Brian you
know we've known each other for several
years now beginning well before you were
arrested and agreed to plead guilty to
lying to the FBI an executive producer
Rhonda Schwartz and I were the only
guests at your wedding in Chicago last
year you would always be special to us
only the first time that would so you've
just had your first year anniversary a
year in which you went to prison for 12
days wrote a book moved to California
talked about running for office and
something else you've changed your story
now George you say in your book you did
not lie to the FBI even though you said
so in court and the judge reduced your
sentence after he said you had shown
remorse for what you did so what is the
story tell us so it's a very complicated
story and that's actually why I had to
write this very lengthy book that took
me six months to actually produce
because there's been such
misunderstanding and misrepresentation
of who George papadopolis as an
individual is and his actual real
involvement in this I guess probe that
consumed the world for the last
two-and-a-half years which has recently
completed with the firm conclusion that
there was actually no conspiracy or no
collusion between
Trump his associates and the Russian
government and quite frankly I predicted
that all along because as I explained in
my book I actually was never really
targeted for my Russia ties but for my
ties to Israel and what all the various
characters in my entire saga turned out
to be something I did not know when I
did plead guilty almost two years ago
now was in fact that these were not
Russian operatives who were engaging
with me but in fact Western intelligence
operatives and possibly working at under
the guidance of the FBI itself when they
were you know meeting with me discussing
various information regarding Russia
emails and various other campaign
activities that I was involved in or
might not have been involved in so
that's really what the story is in a
very superficial lens and angle but I'm
more than happy to get into more details
about it and Simona my wife she actually
became involved directly in the probe
and she could probably share her
thoughts as well but George are you
regretting now that you pleaded guilty
to lying look I have new counsel for a
reason I've been very vocal that I
believe my old counsel and I included in
my book were actually possibly
compromised during the time where they
advised me to plead guilty especially
regarding the obstruction charge which
later Bob Muller himself dropped so my
new counsel has basically advised me
that there are grounds for not only
withdrawing from the guilty plea and
that's something that we were actually
openly discussing all over the media
months before I even reported to my 11
nights in prison but we're actively I
should say they are actively as they are
my counsel not a lawyer they are
currently looking at too into those
options potentially suing the government
on my behalf or seeking apart in itself
if all other recourse doesn't
materialize
well George this is your theory I know
that the whole thing was a deep state
attack on
you and Simona and Donald Trump are you
just saying this now because you're
trying to get a pardon from President
Trump you know a pardon actually it
practically doesn't affect my life one
way or another right now because I've
already served my time and I'm living
happily in Los Angeles with my wife and
were involved in many interesting
projects that have nothing to do with
you know real politics at this moment
but unfortunately the last thing I would
have ever thought I would be doing in my
life is writing a book about the
so-called deep States and what has now
been quite evident and revealed
including my congressional testimony
that has now been publicly released that
in fact I was set up and it was made to
seem like I was in fact up to no good
working with Russians or Russian
intermediaries but that's just not what
happened and my testimony that Congress
reveals that public pronouncements by
congressman Mark Meadows John Radcliffe
and even the President himself
discussing in classifying particular
faisal material regarding my case is
basically portrayed today as information
that could possibly even support the
sitting administration not hurt it so
that's where I'm coming from
I'm not spouting conspiracy theories
everything that's laid out in my book is
a based in fact
George George let me ask you story have
you heard from the White House are you
going to get a pardon as I stated my
lawyers are currently involved in this
matter exclusively I'm not involved
directly or indirectly they believe that
pursuing a pardon would be in my legal
interest and if they are in discussions
with our White House Counsel or the
White House itself they're keeping me
out of it and it's probably best to do
it that way George we've got a question
for you and Simona from the control room
from your friend executive producer
Rhonda Swartz hello
I'm glad they have glad to have you with
us on the show tonight you know we we
were amongst the first reporters I think
to learn that you were under
investigation there was a famous photo
that showed you meeting with President
Trump and with attorney general sessions
and so we understand it you were you
told us that at that meeting you talked
about possibly getting a meeting with
Russia and that they agreed later
sessions said that didn't happen what do
you say about that is that still what
happened at that meeting I've been very
public about this meeting and the
information I'm going to provide here is
the same information I provided to Bob
Muller and the FBI itself
my recollection differs tremendously
from Jeff sessions regarding that events
it's my recollection that jeff sessions
was he was very enthusiastic about the
prospects of Donald Trump not only going
on a foreign policy trip but possibly
meeting Vladimir Putin himself I was so
confident in my you know my statements
and the reaction from it that I
hand-delivered Jeff Sessions my business
card after I made that comment to him
and I then met with Stephen Miller who
at the time was an obscure aide to Jeff
Sessions but now he's obviously a senior
official at the White House and Stephen
Miller and I continue to coordinate for
the subsequent two months regarding
setting up a potential meeting with
Trump and Putin George so the notion
that jeff sessions pushed back against
me and then I continued to attempt to
set up this meeting with senior level
campaign members is absurd one final
question there my first bit Simona one
final question is your husband deserve a
pardon yes sir I think he does and I was
very vocal about that I was the one out
there asking the president Trump to
power down George I remember my very
first interview with George
Stephanopoulos and that Rhonda kindly
introduced me to 12 e C news I mentioned
George as John Dean
and I always highlighted this patriotic
duty to cooperate the with Spencer
council and that's that's also sorry do
you hear me yeah I hear something yes so
I always highlighted this a key role
that revealed to be very different from
the one that has been perceived in the
beginning when I mentioned this
comparison to Jordan but still I think
his life has been posed for too long
I've been living with them this
purgatory
and we are very happy today because our
rehabilitation process open to new
opportunities we are fully enjoying we
are very happy in our life our bond is
very solid as you said it's a love story
in the middle of something that is
probably one of the users investigation
in the last century and you had the
opportunity to know it because you have
been there for day number one and you
are the only two people who attended our
wedding so you will always be special to
us but as I said that George doesn't
have any expectation terms of pardon I
do I do because it's a fair and has been
treated unfairly I think miss
remembering a date it's not a crime we
don't know yet who is Joseph Smith so
that least after two years of
Investigation the FBI didn't figure out
with George me with Joseph Mifsud sorry
not George and I been involved directly
I testified to the Congress and read
recently to the Senate and I gave my own
I shared my own expert on knowledge of
this individual I had the unfortunate
occasion to work with at London sanctum
international law practice omona I
imagine even simona and george
papadapolis thank you thank you very
much thanks for being with us appreciate
it up next another man yeah up next
another man who talks of plots and
conspiracies Alex Jones under earth does
he deserve to be protected by the First
Amendment
after years of broadcasting his ugly and
false conspiracy theories Alex Jones is
now facing a reckoning forced to testify
under oath in a lawsuit brought by
several parents whose children were
killed in the Newtown school shooting a
shooting the Jones at one point claimed
was staged never happened even alleging
that some of the children who were
killed that awful day are actually still
alive we're joined now by Rachel Strama
leading First Amendment lawyer here in
New York to help us understand whether
Jones can win his lawsuit claiming he's
protected by the First Amendment
and Rachel let me show you first a
couple of excerpts of his testimony
questioned by lawyer mark Bankston and I
am I myself with you almost like a
psychosis back in the past where I
basically thought everything was staged
you've not now learned a lot of times
things aren't staged so you know I think
as a pundit and someone giving opinion
that you know my opinions have been
wrong but they were never wrong
consciously to hurt people
so he says it was his opinion he's a
pundits suffering from psychosis his
there first and then the defense for
this man well I don't want to pine on if
he is going to ultimately be found
responsible or not in this lawsuit there
is a First Amendment defense for
opinions that's long been held in our in
our Constitution that the the First
Amendment protects ideas and opinions
and we think the best way of resolving
disputes over opinions is to air them
and have people say they're
countervailing ideas on the other hand
statements of facts can be you can be
responsible for statements of facts if
those facts are wrong and defamatory and
I think the claim here is that that the
parents are arguing that some of his
statements went beyond just opinions an
actual statements of fact that were
defamatory to these parents and their
children he's actually invoked the
important a Supreme Court ruling times
Sullivan which allows all sorts of
statements to be said about something of
great public interest or a public figure
is that a defense for him and isn't it
the fact that you know you test the
First Amendment by some of the worst
cases and he certainly no one really or
not many
carefree what he has to say but is he
protected should he be able to say these
things ugly as they are again not to
sound such like a lawyer I'm not gonna
tell you if I protected in this case or
not no I certainly am and and and a
little cliche one at that but the the
New York Times versus Sullivan case you
talked about is this case from 1964
which says that public officials and
later expanded to public figures can't
bring a defamation claim unless that
they can prove that the person who said
something about them says something not
only false not only defamatory but with
something called actual malice and the
idea there that is they subjectively
believed what they were saying was false
or they entertained subjectively doubts
about what they were saying and went
ahead and said it anyways and I'm quite
confident that the defense attorneys
here that are representing Alex Jones
will be using that that case law to say
that wrong as he was he earnestly
believed it that he was in some
psychosis and and believed it that that
being said the actual malice standard is
extraordinarily high standard and it is
an important standard that we rely on
all the time but it is surmountable it
is something that people can overcome if
the plaintiff is able to show that
Mister Jones showed willful blindness he
chose not to find out what the truth was
and went ahead and started saying false
statements anyways should journalists
support him now since he wants to be
covered by the First Amendment at all
reporters privileges
well again I'm a lawyer not a journalist
and I'm very proud to know the
difference and I think that it makes a
good First Amendment lawyer to not try
to be a journalist and I think that
there's a real debate here about when
someone goes too far and what is real
news versus fake news and and I think
there is a debate between journalists
and you probably can answer that better
than me but it is important to defend
the First Amendment even with somebody
who has says things that a lot of people
don't agree with no doubt no doubt I
mean that the First Amendment is meant
to protect us all not only your belief
the real test is can you stand up for
someone's speech that you don't believe
in for sure well Rachael Strom thank you
very much for joining us and I didn't
for your
insight is a very important question
they coming up our shout out for the
reporters in Dallas looking for answers
about what the dashboard cameras could
not see our shout out tonight to an
investigative reporting team at the
Dallas Morning News that has spent
months of the last six months looking
into one family's claim of police
brutality it was the family's word
against that of the police no one was
killed it's the kind of incident that
might easily get lost in the press of
other news but not for these reporters
it was on a late afternoon last August
when police in the Dallas suburb of
DeSoto responded to a report of a heated
family argument as the police dash
camera shows everything was calm when
the first officer pulled in that was
about to change as the Dallas Morning
News reporters discovered the cops came
in and overheated they they brandished
their weapons for pointing their weapons
that everybody started screaming at them
to get down on them the video shows
Sammy Anderson the mother of four
brothers who had initially asked for
police to be called trying to restrain
one of her sons as more officers arrived
on the scene and tensions continued to
escalate
before long police would use their
tasers against at least one of her sons
leading to a claim of police brutality
Dallas Morning News investigative
reporter miles Moffitt an engagement
reporter LV le monde heard about the
incident from the local civil rights
group and began to review the police
videos
I mean you could see a lot of you know
aggressive actions on their part and the
family being very confused asking
questions themselves not immediately
responding to their orders to get on the
ground as you can imagine because they
didn't understand why you know their
actions were so aggressive and also
again pointing tasers at their face and
it's gone out of control
so the dash cam it had presented a
fairly confusing sequence of events the
family later told the reporters they
felt they had been brutalized and had
only called the police because they
trusted the officers to calm the
situation not make it worse
this family told us that they had so
much trust in their Police Department
you know they're from a suburb so most
of the time you know they see at the
police all the time the reporters could
not clearly make out what exactly
happened given the wide angle view from
the patrol car dash cam but they also
knew the solo police were supposed to
wear body cameras so you know it became
really imperative to get the body cams
so we could have close-up detail it took
months before police released the body
cam video so we get the body cam and the
body cam you know is is murky one video
is black the officer was wearing it and
during the tasing at least four cameras
were were not activated and we don't
know why leaving lots of questions about
just how many times in this scene Grant
Bible one of the sons was subjected to
taser
that night he suffered a hemorrhage to
his eye and his mom says she believes
her she saw an officer activate his
taser close to his head
so the question is did his eye injury
come as a result of the tasing and what
else was happening what else was
happening on that that closely-knit
crowding but with what body cam footage
they could obtain the Dallas Morning
News photo editor Marcia Allard had
videographer Brad Ellis put together a
compelling synced up version of what
happened it was actually Marcia's idea
as she said I think we need a Steven
Soderbergh like effect here and and what
she was saying is the multiple
perspectives so viewers themselves can
draw their own conclusion the timeline
clearly showing how the situation so
quickly escalated at the hands of the
officers the police chief says his
officers acted properly but one result
of the Dallas Morning News reporting was
that the district attorney dropped all
charges against two of the brothers who
were arrested that night although it
took months for that to happen some of
the brothers lost their jobs because
they were in jail when this happened
as for the DeSoto Police Department
we're still waiting for some kind of
response from them and so far we're just
not hearing back but thanks to the
reporting efforts the two brothers at
least have now been cleared of charges
that should never had been brought in
the first place yeah it feels really
good we were able to go to the
courthouse and just kind of see them
release some balloons the day they
that's with two brothers picture we -
yeah we're exonerated and you know they
it just feels like a weight off their
shoulders no doubt a great feeling
so our shout out tonight to the team at
the Dallas Morning News for showing how
investigative journalism can make such a
difference sometimes it means people who
break the law end up in jail but it's
even better when journalists help people
wrongly accused and help them get out of
jail I've seen that again many times in
our
courting so once again hats off a shout
out to the Dallas Morning News for some
great work that's our program tonight
thanks for joining us we'll see you
again right back here next week